[Music]
these are photos of an island in the
South Pacific the place where myth and
science me we use explosives to shake
the earth helping us to map the surface
of the island you're dropping bombs
scientific insurance
magnificent
you knew that thing was out here I'm
sorry for your man car but if you want
to make this sacrifice worthwhile get us
home with proof monsters exist
[Music]
your friend there can put that down what
the hell is this place
that's calm he's King around here comes
pretty good King keeps to himself mostly
well you don't go into someone's house
and start dropping bombs unless you're
picking a fight call his God on the
island but the devil's live below us
then what are they called
I call skull why never said that name
out loud before it sounds stupid now
that I say just you call him whatever
you want
[Music]
it's a good group of boys we're all
gonna die together out here
a rescue George he was 2 years old he's
not just a friend he's family don't move
a muscle
are you crazy very funny you and I
laughing at your joke new guy you know
Bob he cry you can get up now
and check your diaper come on let's go
are you message about Georgie ok George
it's ok
as in mirrors he considerably bigger
though he's definitely bigger need to
find someone who knows exactly what the
hell this thing is
I found her no that's a lie technically
she found us what's happening to my
friend are you familiar with genetic
editing changes would be incredibly
unpredictable increased strength George
speed agility
cells and stains that came run Where's
George I need to see him he is dangerous
I think it's time for me to turn the man
we've created the next chapter in
natural selection project rampage works
got another one of your little science
experiments running around we meet
another one of course the wolf lives
this time we throw everything we can at
these things and get people the hell out
of that city let's go save the world
that's a big arm don't fight it
you know there are other ways of dealing
with people I do know that yeah but
that's not fun George okay ready to do
this buddy
hello
is anyone there
I'm trying to reach
[Music]
senators we believe that these Titans
are just the tip of the iceberg which of
these Titans are here to protect us and
which of these Titans are here to
threaten us
[Music]
so you'd want to make Godzilla our pet
no we would be his you're sure he's
gonna be okay
they're everywhere battling for
dominance
arrival alpha to Godzilla you gotta be
kidding
[Music]
on the GPS it's unworthy of global
positioning that's stole points get off
the grid right oh I'm thinking this
thing doesn't take credit cards
climb stairs closed we're looking for
what's called Tillerman Road how to get
you there
getting back Wow
[Applause]
the labs have passed to the gate they
are come to the killing floor seriously
believe Susan it is going on
what is it we have to stay together
right yeah gotta get out of here
nobody said those things here you're
missing the point
they wanna see us
I think
what is that called alien broth believe
it and landed in the wrong place tall
you get me wrong place you discovered a
species here but to unknown to science
believe maybe there was a party at the
zoo and the monkey shag to fish
yo check it wha-wha-what them tinks ah
lovely fireworks humanitarian invasion
curses I'm killing them I'm killing them
straight let's get to lot black quite
sweet really only that's different
learning the same thing for disaster we
need to get off the streets back in a
block
what kind of aliens with invade
sometimes will state in South London one
was looking for a fact
what is that I'm pissing myself in it
but at the same time this is sick
look at one text left too much madness
just being in one tank
has to call the police tells us no one's
gonna ever remain you keep acting that
such a Russia
see safe did you give this on the shelf
if it's in a yurt or it's in your book
you can't get rid of the father talk but
Baba Dook Dook Dook
I wants to scare you first then you'll
see it this monster thing has got to
stop
you can't get lured into Feathertop
[Music]
you can't get rid of the babadook it's
15
[Music]
let's go back to the car
dogs don't taste like this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're fine
Samuel it's gonna be a bit
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
mom are you positive that there weren't
any other places looking for Vice
Principals you promised you could be
shot I promise and I looked into it
legally I can't live on my own until I'm
18
[Music]
yeah I'm Zach by the way
I'm Hannah get away from the window now
I gotta go hi
and we're just moving in you see that
fence on your side of it he's a big
teddy bear
don't take it personally it doesn't
really like anyone yeah Hannah's in
trouble
Oh she's locked in this house and her
dad's a psychopath
does she have a friend
[Music]
The Abominable Snowman of Pasadena these
are all goosebumps manuscripts why are
these books locked did you unlock a book
oh no I'm sorry
I'll put it back where it belongs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ton of cavities ten I didn't brush my
teeth for a whole year we cannot let the
monsters inside
[Music]
No maybe they're friendly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]